anyway so you did girl code good girl
code yeah that's a big audience it was
like something bigger than like I would
have ever imagined yeah even today I was
I was shopping at the Grove yeah and the
girl was like you're really funny and
I'm like oh that's good why I didn't say
anything and she was like hey I watch on
girlcode do you when people recognize
you there are certain things when they
recognize you kind of go uh what do you
mean like some people go to me like hey
I love you on something that I don't
even remember doing really yeah it's
never like something cool like I love
doing in the dictator or whatever it's
always like you know I love you in like
Joe's YouTube video highlight clip yeah
the worst is when they make you they
don't remember where they know you
yeah you tell you know what I say what
sit go hey I know you from something
what were you in not nothing I know I
don't I grew the guy I have a day job
I'm a busboy a PF Changs
that's a long walk away guys Bobby just
told a blatant lie oh he's
smiling stop go ahead expose me I don't
think you're your fraud I just think
that it makes me uncomfortable when you
start to roll out your credits to people
to strangers and they're like what do
you do no no no you're from this and
he's like do you see me here how about
this one babe babe I've done that too no
I do it yeah yeah we go see Nora I know
but you just told him you didn't do that
no I do do it sometimes sometimes I do
the other way multiple options goddamn
anyway we I hate that tune Nora okay
how'd you do that
maybe I'm blushing after Ville jumping
on that has any
[Music]